this is one of the main causes of the
climate crisis
humans have for centuries raised the
world's forests which naturally protect
the planet by absorbing carbon dioxide
but an agreement cop 26 if the words are
matched by action could be a
breakthrough more than a hundred nations
have pledged to reverse deforestation by
twenty thirty
forests have the potential to reduce
reduce carbon globally by more than one
third
by more than one-third
so we need to approach this issue with
the same seriousness of purpose
as decarbonizing our economies
florence so importance for me another
leader the president of brazil the
country with half the planet's tropical
forests jaya bolsonaro also supported
the initiative in a video statement even
though activists say the destruction has
soared during his term
in addition to the announcement on
forest another important development a
new initiative to cut methane levels
again signed by over 100 countries by
the year 2030 methane doesn't stay in
the atmosphere as long as carbon dioxide
but it's 80 times more potent in warming
the earth
despite some positive developments there
are still worries about a lack of
ambition from those gathered here
frankly speaking
there is no dignity to a slow and
painful death you might as well bomb our
islands instead of making us suffer only
to witness our slow and faithful demise
leaders of the g20 we are drowning and
our only hope
is the life ring you are holding
that theme of the western nations not
doing enough was again reflected when
representatives from more than 20
african countries called for more
support for the continent the un
secretary general antonio guterres has
warned that divisions between the
developed and developing world could
completely derail this vital summit
james bay's al jazeera glasgow